can you tell it to do any infinity woke
up in the middle of it I think that the
Guardians just shot their part when it
comes to infinity Wars like the first
card and we all have to go back to
gauntlet later this year
hey youtubers is Charlie there was ever
notification squad this is it we know
what part two of infinity war is going
to be so I'll explain what that means it
just because this is also awesome
there's a new round of the Spider Man
giveaway that starts now all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber leave a
comment on this video so if you're
confused with zoe saldana basically said
is that she was going back to shoot
gauntlet when she was talking about the
Infinity Gauntlet as in infinity War
part 2 remember Kevin Feige said that
they changed the name the Russos are
like we're changing the name because the
second movie is so different from the
first so with about 99.9% certainty we
can now ascertain that the first
infinity war film or we'll just call it
infinity war is mostly going to be based
on the sanno square storyline from the
comics which I'll explain in a second
and then the fourth Avengers film will
be based on the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline so previously like the big
difference is is that we thought that
they were going to do the Infinity
Gauntlet storyline with the infinity war
movie and then they were going to do
like all-new all-different it was going
to be some universe changing rebirthing
so now it actually makes a little more
sense and I actually think that they
made the smart decision to split up that
Bannos storyline because think about it
this way if you get to infinity war even
if it's a two-and-a-half-hour movie you
have to spend most of that movie with
him going around collecting all the gems
then placing them in the gauntlet and
then deciding what to do you have to
spend all this time setting up his story
life because yes as comic-book readers
we know exactly what happened during
that story but most people going to see
the movie have never read that so they
saw the teaser at the end of the first
Avengers film so you know a little bit
about Thanos just based on the way that
they've set him up in the MCU you saw
him in guardians of the galaxy you know
that he gave Loki the sceptre with the
mine gem in it but you don't really
understand his motivation why he's doing
it what his grand plan is so that will
be revealed during infinity war and he
will go around kicking the asses of
every single Avenger and anyone else
like the Nova Corps that possesses an
infinity gem remember the Nova Corps
still has the power gem the collector
still has the reality gem the soul gem
is still missing in action we believe
it's with hella right now but to be
determined as of Thor Ragnarok so
instead of short
changing fan OSes storyline they're
going to give it the grandeur that it
deserves and that's going to take two
separate movies so the funny thing on
all this is they kevin feige actually
teased that the second infinity war
title was going to be a spoiler but it's
not really a spoiler because they're
just doing the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline which we already thought that
they were going to do so Santos Quest is
a storyline that's completely different
from the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
it's the story of how Fanus goes around
collecting all the gems from the
different cosmic entities and elders of
the universe the difference in the comic
book in the way they've done it in the
MCU
is that Thanos is literally interacting
with the cosmic entity death and she
realizes that there is a cosmic
imbalance there are more people alive
today than have ever died so she feels
like that is a great imbalance and
Santos is ordered to correct it so he
wants to win her hand
their relationship is totally hilarious
through this whole experience
she speaks through an avatar who just
conveys her wishes to Thanos and she
just stands there refusing to answer him
directly so it pisses the hell out of
Thanos that he goes around and collects
the gems the first gem he goes for is
the soul gem which is funny because it's
the last gem that we've seen in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so that's one
of the big things that they'll change
the orders that the anos goes for the
gems and so you may have heard about
behind the scenes vision stuff that
they're filming right now where he's
fighting the cold obsidian presumably
those are the Cole obsidian that have
come to take the mind gem and bring it
back to Thanos so that's sort of getting
into more modern storylines because way
back when they did this Infinity
Gauntlet I Thanos quest story there was
no Coll obsidian he did have minions but
he was the main character of the story
and he went around himself collecting
all the gems but then later during
Marvel's infinity event which is a much
more recent storyline he had his minions
the Cole obsidian going around searching
for the gems as well as searching for
his son which is kind of a separate
thing so it's totally normal for them to
pull from all over the comics but
largely the plot is pulled from Santos
quest so he goes around to all the
different elders of the universe and
different cosmic entities that have the
gems he assembles them and then at the
end of the storyline when he's done this
in service of lady debt he gets the idea
that
you know what I have all this power I'm
going to do what I want to do with it I
can do anything I want and then everyone
that's standing around in the realm of
death is like oh wait a minute
he just figured out that he doesn't have
to do what we say because he wields
infinite power now so that sets him on
the path to try and win lady death as
his hand so he does all these things to
try and impress her and you get into the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline so the story
of phantos quest is just getting the
gems before he assembles the gauntlet
then the Infinity Gauntlet is the story
of what he does
once he assembles the gauntlet in the
avengers fighting him trying to take it
down so we can make a couple really easy
predictions based on that so if it's
going to take the entire movie for
Santos to assemble the Infinity Gauntlet
then it's also probably going to take
Tony Stark the entire movie to assemble
the intergalactic Avengers because the
guardians of the galaxy are part of the
movie so there'll be a little bit of
crossover with the Avengers but they are
two separate teams but cap is still a
fugitive of the state Captain Marvel
hasn't even got her powers yet black
panther is still trying to take care of
his own homeland there's still a big
uprising that he has to put down that's
going to be part of the Black Panther
movie in most of Iron Man's time right
now is spent shepherding young Peter
Parker into a greater life as an Avenger
like trying to help him along on his
path so everybody is busy doing other
things so what happened at the beginning
of the Infinity Gauntlet storyline is
that Silver Surfer Herald of Galactus
was actually Herald of the doom that fan
OHS was bringing so he comes to earth
and he tells Doctor Strange look I might
be too late but Thanos is assembling the
gauntlet these are the terrors that he's
going to unleash on the universe so
Doctor Strange is really the first
avenger that finds out what's going on
and then you kind of jump around to all
the big characters and at the very
beginning of the story
you see fan oh snap his fingers in a
race half of all life so all of a sudden
spider-man Spidey sensors goes off the
charts oh my god where did Mary Jane go
where did all these people on the street
that I was just looking at go
so is this big crazy epic adventure but
what they might do just you know just a
99% positive that he's going to assemble
the gauntlet at the end of the first
infinity war film and they'll end on the
oh crap cliffhanger to end all
cliffhangers when he snaps his fingers
in a
races half of all life in the universe
now this is speculation but for instance
nebula said that she is going to be in
infinity where Karen Gillan's already
been to the set most of the guardians
have already filmed their infinity war
scenes now in the movie that's just a
story of Thanos collecting the gems the
second part the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline is really interesting for
nebula she said that she hopes that it
goes down the way it does in the comics
for her character so that would mean
that Karen Gillan actually gets to wear
the Infinity Gauntlet in turns against
Thanos so I highly recommend that you
reread Thanos quest and then the
Infinity Gauntlet storyline but Thanos
is the worst dad ever if you think that
he's dismissive of her during guardians
of the galaxy then wait till you read
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline he tries
to impress Lady Death with the way he
mistreats nebula
so nebula turns against him and it's the
story of how they trick fan oohs into
immobilizing himself so that she can
take the gauntlet herself in an eventual
II Adam warlock gets it and you all know
that they tease the Adam warlock will
show up in the Marvel Universe
eventually but probably not till after
the big infinity war Infinity Gauntlet
storyline but they can change anything
they want but remember that they've
largely finished the script for both of
these movies they wrote them
back-to-back and they're going to be
filming this Infinity Gauntlet the
fourth Avengers film towards the end of
this year so let me know in the comments
where do you want them to leave off with
infinity war like what do you want that
final moment to be remember danos
assembling the gauntlet the fourth
Avengers film will be the story of what
he does when he has the gauntlet and how
the Avengers get it off of him and fixed
the universe so a lot of you are also
asking what does this say about Josh
Brolin playing fan OHS in the Marvel
Universe if he's going to be cable and
he signed up for four movies they're not
all going to be Deadpool movies but he
signed a four film contract so he's
going to be very busy playing cable so
Kevin Feige did the cool thing he was
totally awesome about this he said that
I see no problem with him playing
somebody else in another film universe
it's not a big deal in most of his time
filming Thanos is motion capture this is
a picture of him on the set with the
Russos at the beginning of infinity war
so it's not going to be a big problem
and after that next Avengers film fan
OHS is going to be on ice for a long
time it's not like you go through the
Gauntlet saga and then come right back
or he gets sucked into the Dark
Dimension and bites Dormammu for a while
but I definitely think that Dormammu and
other big cosmic entities will rise in
his absence as they move past this big
Avengers arc so that's another big
question let me know after Thanos is
done with the Infinity Gauntlet saga
with both of these next Avengers films
who do you want the new Big Bad the
Marvel Cinematic Universe to be I just I
feel like it has to be Dormammu if
they're not going to do Mephisto or some
other big cosmic entity leave all your
requests for more Marvel Avengers videos
in the comments below there's so much
Marvel stuff happening really soon but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner Carl Peterson please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for that you can click here for
my non-spoilery guardians of the galaxy
to review and you can click here for a
brand new spider-man homecoming promo
and new Iron Man armor thank you so much
for watching let's high five I'll see
you guys in the next video